this is a foxnews literally want to
bring you tonight the president just
made a surprise announcement acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
is leaving he will be replaced by
congressman Mark Meadows the president
just tweeted this quote I'm pleased to
announce that congressman mark meadows
will become White House chief of staff
I have long known and worked with mark
and the relationship is a very good one
I want to thank acting chief McMullen II
for having served this administration so
well he'll become the United States
special envoy for Northern Ireland we
will continue to follow this of course